الى مكان ما في افغانستان فرت مروه
واولادها مكان غير معلوم حتى لوالدتها
مروه ام لثمانيه اطفال ست فتيات وطفلين
نالت مطلبها بالطلاق من زوجها قبل استيلاء
طالبان على السلطه بسته اشهر لكنها اليوم
تختبئ اطفالها لان طالبان الحاكمه الغى
الطلاقها من زوجها
كان دائما يختلق الاسباب لضربي ومنها انه
يريد اطفالا ذكورا بعدد اكبر
هنا في هذا البلد حيث يتنام القهر والخوف
لدى فئه هي الاكثر استضعافا نساء
افغانستان
9 من كل عشر نساء يقعن ضحايا العنف الجسدي
والجنسي والنفسي من جانب شريكهن بحسب بعثه
الامم المتحده في البلاد
مروه اختارت الغربه في بلدها لا تعرف احدا
وتخشى اعلام حتى والدتها بمكانها خوفا من
ان تعثر عليها السلطات اختارت خياطه
الملابس مهنه تعتاش منها وربما من سخريه
القدر ان المحامي التي لجات اليها مروه
اسمها ظريفه وهو اسم وهمي اختارته خوفا من
طالبان التي منعتها عن ممارسه عملها تحاول
مروى الاختفاء قد تنجو وربما لا لكن
محاميتها المفترضه تقول ان حاله مروه ليست
الوحيده فضريفه تلقت على الاقل خمسه
اتصالات في الاشهر الماضيه من نساء مطلقات
يطلبن مساعدتها حنان المصري العربيه